We will overcome that barrier.
So, we would want to answer the questions
that the users are not asking
or they don't even know
how to ask the questions.
Ramesh Panuganty,
thank you so much for being on my show.
How are you?
I'm good, Michael.
Thanks for calling, yeah.
Thank you very much for being here.
It's a privilege to have you here.
A serial entrepreneur.
I think that you are the definition
of a serial entrepreneur
with three successful companies
behind you already.
All of them were acquired.
Some of them by companies
that I value very much.
I think that until today,
I still use Splunk
on a pretty regular basis.
And now, you're on
to your fourth startup.
And I'm very proud
to be a part of the journey
as a part of J-Ventures,
one of the investors in the company.
And so, before we get to talk about
what this latest company is about.
Ramesh, I'd love for you to take me back
a little bit.
And what is it about entrepreneurship
and about building companies
that really gets you so excited?
Because now,
you're on to your fourth one.
So, instead of calling it
as an entrepreneurship,
let me just say that it was more about
being passionate than being about
trying to change the world
in like a smaller way.
And even before
I was starting my first company,
I thought there is actually
a big product market gap
in terms of what was happening
with the evolution of the cloud.
The Amazon Web Services
have just started.
There's probably less than 50 people
when I first interacted with them.
And I thought there is a big opportunity
in terms of,
say, what the cloud
could do for the world
and how people
can even get on to the cloud.
And coming from an
experience and operating systems.
I started my journey
in operating systems.
The first product I
tried to add and build
was SVR for UNIX operating system.
I spent about six years
on UNIX operating system
trying to add features,
make changes,
and then a new configuration things
like clustering.
So, I've come from the space,
what we've done always for about 12 years
or so across companies,
like Sun Microsystems StorageTek, etc.
And I thought there is an opportunity
to migrate enterprise applications
from one printer cloud
and also manage these applications.
When I first started
selling the product to the customers,
not many customers even knew about AWS.
So, it was actually really hard
for them to be convinced
to even take a meeting.
Not just us,
we used to partner with AWS,
so we went for AWS sales reps.
And then, we eventually succeeded.
I grew the business
to about 40 million dollars
[--].
And cloud management platforms
was the one that I created.
But it was less about
being an entrepreneur
or trying to do something.
But the idea was about being passionate
about the technical problem
and trying to solve it.
So, when you talk about, you know,
changing the world in your capacity
throughout these companies,
it sounds to me also
that while you're talking about that,
you all you're also excited
about the technologies
that you're building, right?
These are things
that you're personally curious about
and personally passionate about.
Yeah.
So, all of these companies are very
technologically centric companies.
Think of it as an IP centric company
in a very positive way
and not in a negative way.
And I'm very passionate about
using the technology
to make a meaningful change
for somebody.
And even in the second company,
I thought we could use an MP
in a completely different way
to create a conversation.
And 2014
was when we applied for the trademark
of conversational analytics.
And then, that was the company
that I had created.
And then, we were able to create
a meaningful impact
on enterprise customers.
Of course, we got an acquisition offer
much early in the cycle,
which we could not refuse.
So, we were acquired by Splunk.
But the conversational analytics with me,
meaning it was less about NFV.
We did not use any
open source NFV package.
No stand for NFV.
No other NFV.
So, we had to build the grounds up.
Most of the code
was actually done in assembly.
Really?
We were probably,
only one of the four, five companies
in the whole of Bay Area
who were working on assembly.
So, we wanted to give that experience,
speed and performance on NFV.
Now, I don't think
I can that actually do that.
But it is about
being passionate to that level.
That's just incredible.
So, passionate to that level.
One of four or five companies
working an assembly
out of the Bay Area in 2014, 2015.
That's just incredible.
So, give me
a spectrum of the technologies
that today in 2020
you're personally excited about.
I'm very excited about NLP.
And I focus a lot of my time at Stanford
on artificial intelligence
of the different applications
that it's going to.
But I'd love to pick your brain
on the different things
that you're particularly excited about
as we enter a new decade now.
As any entrepreneur has to do,
I'm very focused.
So, it is not about AI in general,
but application of AI
to solve a very specific problem.
In the current company, in MachEye,
we use AI as an architecture
to give a play button
for the enterprise data
and also to solve a big problem
in AI and to act.
I'll explain what do I mean
by play button for the enterprise data.
So, think of it as
we are bringing
two or three different things in AI
together to provide this benefit.
Number 1 is a Google like
actual search experience,
and it is a lot more than NLP.
And it is about
bringing in an actual search experience
coupled with ambiguity corrections,
coupled with contextual
search recommendations, etc.
It means that
when a customer is searching
for say, it's Alabama,
we have to figure out
whether Alabama is country,
or a city, or a state, etc. and so on,
that is done by us.
And second,
we understand not only the query,
we answer back instantly.
But we also get the raw data
and apply a series
of machine learning ones.
And even though
there are a lot of platforms
where somebody
can drag and drop the models
and analyze,
but it doesn't happen
for every enterprise user.
So think of it as a
a coffee store manager
of a large chain.
That store manager
cannot deal with all these models.
So, we do this ML workflow,
ML operations on the fly
at that point in time.
Typical turn around time,
about 300 milliseconds.
Wow.
And we actually choose
the machine learning models.
We do the
feature parameter identification,
but some of this can happen
in an offline basis, too.
And then finally,
we use energy to produce English.
And then added it as an audio visual.
So, I assume that
a business user is on the go
and he asks the question:
how many chairs do I order
say for an upcoming season?
So, think of it as a retail customer.
And he simply gets an audio visual
on the mobile phone
and starts talking saying that
these are the number of chairs
that you need to order.
But along with the chairs,
you need to buy a tabletop.
Because 38% of the customers
buy tables along with the chairs.
So, this is something
that we need to look at.
So, that intelligence we try to bring up
and then presented at that point in time.
So, that is what we are doing
at MachEye.
And we have built a product
with AI as an architecture
rather than AI as a feature.
So, one of the things
that I'm always curious about is focus.
And one of the things that you mentioned
when I talked about
how I enjoy, you know, exploring
the artificial intelligence field
at Stanford,
you mentioned that as an entrepreneur,
and as a CEO, you enjoy taking AI
into an application level
and solving a real problem,
not just with the
artificial intelligence slowly,
but actually
one of the applications of it.
So, I'm curious,
within a software like MachEye
and within a company
that seems to be doing a lot, right,
you're solving a lot
of different problems in one,
how do you maintain focus
on which are
the really crucial problems to solve
especially if you're just starting out
and you're just exploring
what are your users are doing?
Yes. So, how do we identify the problem?
Number 1, first, trying to identify
what is the business scenario.
So, the business scenario
or the context is business intelligence.
And the business intelligence,
you define the persona.
And then you identify
what these are,
and then try to do that.
Say for example,
in this particular business
intelligence as a market, I think,
there is no use of any [--],
it's just as an example.
And hence, we don't do anything
like I mention,
educational intermediary identification
even though it is AI.
But it is more of understanding of data,
understanding or uncovering
the intelligence that is in the data,
automatically to the user.
So, that is a big business call.
And the long term vision of us
is to be a personal business companion
of any enterprise data.
As long as the technology
can fit into the scope and the use case,
we try to stay very focused on that.
So, if you're looking, you know,
10 years in the future about where,
how businesses are utilizing data
to leverage both
their day to day activities,
but also their forecasts
and as they scale,
where are we today
and where do you think
the world will be in 10, 15 years or so?
In terms of where the world is
as of no hour as of yesterday,
without MachEye is that,
a user has to,
or the entire data industries
in this paradigm
of what you ask is what you get.
So, I assume that the business user
wants to know something.
Say, for example,
somebody is asking a question:
how much were the California wildfires
this year?
Okay. It is actually really hard
to get an answer.
But you see, you can get an answer
by way of analyze,
looking at various information,
writing a sequel, etc.
But nothing more than
what the user is asking.
And I envision that pretty soon.
Say us, or maybe other companies
that are going to come up
in the same space.
We will overcome that barrier.
So, we would want to answer the questions
that the users are not asking,
or they don't even know
how to ask the questions.
Say, for example,
in this particular scenario,
the California wildfires,
we were told that the wildfires in 2020
has been little over 15 times
of the last year,
or 2020 wildfires were greater than
the sum total of the last
four or five years.
So, that is an intelligence
that the user doesn't know.
And then we could tell that.
And eventually,
what we are working on already
is to be able to produce
this intelligence
without any questions at all.
So, I assume that
we will become click-less,
and also search-less product.
So, I assume that
if I know the business metrics
and the KPIs
that the users are interested in,
we would want to produce intelligence
even without them asking any questions.
And we do that
to some extent already.
And that is how I think
enterprise intelligence will move.
So, what have you learned
over the past three companies
that you've built
about the life cycle of a companies?
So,
either as an entrepreneur
or as a leader or business wise,
what are some really key insights
that you've generated for yourself
as you are now approaching
or you're in the midst
of your fourth venture?
As an entrepreneur
and as a founder of the company,
this one very important thing
to figure out is,
is there an existing market
that we are going after.
Or are we creating a new market,
new product category.
Say in our case,
it is business intelligence as a market.
And there are budgets,
and the customers
have budget cycles.
And then
it means
that there is also competition
that is a legacy competition
or incumbent vendor.
And it is very important to identify
the difference between these two:
existing or new.
Because the market positioning,
customers budgets,
everything depends on that.
If you're trying to create a new product,
completely new product,
it's a longer sales cycle.
And customers don't have budget.
They can only budget
for a POC this year
and then budget for the,
for the complete implementation
end of next year or two years or so.
So, that is actually the first one
that you need to decide.
And the second thing is,
what is the value add
for the customer.
You can build great,
but if it doesn't deliver
a customer value, again,
customers may not perceived
a value in that.
And third, is that
can your product
stand up on its own,
or does it need an ecosystem
of other things
that need to push the adaption.
So, if somebody can understand
these three things,
it's easier to sell.
Were there any challenges
that kept presenting themselves
that almost seemed
to get easier and easier
with every venture
but they were the same in nature?
So, the same challenge
but you were able to tackle it
with more and more experience?
It is not always the same challenge.
Because if in case you see a challenge,
most of the times in the next venture,
you are better prepared
and you don't see the same challenge.
It is probably a different challenge
that you will encounter.
And in this company,
if I had to tell what is
a technological challenge
that we had to overcome,
was a synchronicity
of this machine learning models.
Some of these models
can take a long time to execute.
And if I had to take the input
from the search
and then instantly produce
the minimum 300 millisecond,
some models may not respond in the time .
So, we had to build an audio
or video engine that works
in synchronicity in nature.
So, it means that
as a video starts playing,
we might start appending content to it.
So, the progress bar
can sometimes go backwards
and not just forward.
Because the total time increased,
But we try to make sure that
that experience is seamless
and also present the user experience now
is an easy matter. So, yeah.
What are some other
interesting plans
that you're excited about?
So, obviously a lot of it
is in the world
of what MachEye is doing now,
but what are some other
big picture problems
that you think are worth tackling,
if for example,
young entrepreneurs from Stanford,
or 8200, are listening to this?
I think there is a big opportunity
in the educational space
coming from having built a company
in the educational space,
and in my select few other company,
I think that there is a lot more
bigger opportunity.
The existing platforms and solutions
are a bit monotonous.
And they don't personalized the content,
they don't personalized the delivery.
There is a lot of opportunity.
And as an entrepreneur,
somebody would also have a guarantee
that people would pay for that stuff,
pay for the products that they consume.
So education, in my opinion,
is on the top of the funnel.
And after that,
I think insurance and health care,
I think could go through a lot of change,
assuming that the government don't stop
some things coming into the AI space.
100%.
I mean, obviously with health care,
we've seen a dramatic
acceleration of change
and adaption in 2020.
And I myself,
am also a part of a Hippo Insurance,
an InsureTech company
based in the Bay Area.
So, I can see firsthand
the revolution
that insurance is going through
in this past few years,
and it's just remarkable.
Ramesh, thank you again for both
for coming on the show
and sharing your insights,
but also for allowing myself
and J-Ventures to be a part of your,
hopefully your new success story.
And it's still, it's a remarkable,
I think, for me to think of sitting
in front of somebody who's done it
three times already,
successfully going on the fourth one.
But at the end,
it's not about the money
and it's not about the fame.
It's about being passionate
about the technology,
and passionate about,
about improving the lives
of either people or companies,
or people that are working
their day to day
to ask the most meaningful questions.
And I think that it's really remarkable.
Before we leave,
I have to ask you
the most important question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
And why those three words.
So, the three words
I'm just thinking on the fly.
So, number one is that
I'm very passionate.
About trying to solve the problem,
whether it is working, say,
12 hours, 14 hours a day.
And the second thing is,
I'm very compassionate to the team.
And then I try to think
from their perspective to understand them
and then make sure that I help them.
I encourage them to get things done.
And the third is fun part of it,
making sure that
it's so fun experience every day.
I love it.
Ramesh, thank you so, so much.
This is so great.
Best of luck with the company.
And I look forward
to keep working with you
over these next few years.
Okay. And thank you for asking
all the good set of questions.
And I appreciate all the enrollment
and then trying to do this.
And good luck with J-Ventures.
Thank you very much. Take care
Okay, thank you. Bye.